[Music]
we've got to stop meeting up like this
welcome back to playstation grenade i'm
adam this is the series in which we take
a look at the story of batman
and his adventures on the fortnite
island issue five the penultimate
episode in the saga
is now available and like always i'm
here to break it down add a little
context
a few bad jokes a smidge of easter eggs
and a trolley load of fortnite law
if you enjoy what you see please smash
code adamaru in the store but a light
goes a long way too
so if you're ready and your butt is sat
down let's go through everything you
need to know about issue 5
of batman fortnite
zero point
last time we met we saw batman and his
crew go into the underground facility
thanks to those secret bunkers but the
team lost a member when fishnicks was
brutally eliminated by a double agent
in the group so this is the current
scenario who do you think
is the main suspect who's the enemy
among us
also another one of these characters
will be off in this issue too so get
your guesses in who's the next to be
eliminated
before we can even contemplate this idea
the group are attacked by io guards the
very same ones we see in game
right now to be clear the imagined order
hasn't been named in the series so far
but i'm sure you are aware that the io
troopers wear the reality waves on their
crest
which is the exact same as the io logo
the group are close to losing this
firefight and things get worse when
reinforcements arrive
luckily not the ones they expected it's
batman he catches up to the group after
staying with fish sticks until the end
and now turns the battle in the favor of
the loop escape piece
no batman and catwoman use their
superior hand-to-hand combat skills
to end this fight but then magnus joins
in with his axe
and my axe and batman's all like hey
we don't kill people my guy that's not
cool there's a theory behind this
unlike in the loop our eliminations out
here are effectively murder
there's no respawns so i can see what
bats is saying
and if you ever wonder why batman
refuses to kill people
check this if i allow myself to go down
into that place
i'll never come back
batman also wants to keep the io troops
alive for interrogation and takes off
the mask off the fallen guard
okay who the heck is that batman says he
recognizes him from the loop
so he's definitely someone we've already
seen i'm gonna go for a jonezy snapshot
as we all know john d is the most
duplicated character in the game
and has the most snapshots on the island
it's highly likely that
at some point he has been in the center
of the final circle claiming a vic roy
alternatively voyages theories are quite
sound too
maybe they plucked skilled combatants
from the loop
to use a security batman isn't convinced
as the entire i o troops fought like a
military unit with years of experience
bravo 6 going dark
other theories thrown out include a
cloning facility or a multiverse of
worlds linking dimensions
both brilliant theories and both coming
from deathstroke
hmm he has bigger brain than i remember
the band of heroes continue into the
underground facility and batman casually
lets everyone know that fish dix
is dead killed by an energy beam but
that memorial for a fallen comrade is
quickly forgotten
as the group reach a brand new room deep
underground
a meeting room of sorts is found
surrounded by ancient artifacts
many of which can be found in game right
now as we all know batman has
skills skills and during this whole
adventure
bruce has been deciphering this unknown
language
here's another piece of law batman uses
the new skill to read
a star chart nearby and would you
believe it all the planets and stars
are overlapping like they are connected
somehow
but yet again the group want to move on
especially deathstroke and catwoman who
comments this place
feels wrong and gets her hackles up okay
i didn't know what a hackle was so i
used google to help me understand
and it's those erect hairs on animals
when they feel threatened
are you glad you came today the more you
know more time passes and once again the
group are in a battle
yet this time they are cornered by two
io units
deathstroke gets big brain again and
tells batman to use his liquid nitrogen
capsules
how the hell does he know what they are
i i guess we just let that slide
as bruce is completely on board with the
plan batman eats the capsules and slade
uses his energy weapon to detonate the
nitrogen like a grenade
this now makes it a fair fight between
our gang and the rest of the io troops
no after the fighting has settled we get
a real
wow point of the issue batman leads this
band of misfits into a room
you may recognize ring any bells
think back to season 5 and the day we
saw jonesy grab the portal device and
march into
this very room the control panel the
glass-like paint the matching ceiling
design
unless there are multiple versions of
this very room
batman is literally across the hall from
agent jones's office
suddenly eternal voyager gets excited
and believes his purpose is to jump into
the zero point
thinking it would send him around the
multiverse like his name suggests he
wants to be an eternal voyager and
explore the universe
forever
i'm batman well that was a terrible idea
voyager was immediately ripped apart by
the zero point with pieces of him torn
into multiple worlds across
numerous planets let's not concentrate
on how gory that was
if you look closely enough you'll see
many of the dimensions he's going to
in in pieces there's a world full of
fish sticks rest in peace
there's a primal lizard dinosaur kind of
planet
a world filled with spaceships and my
personal favorite
a planet with two moons i originally
thought this was a star wars reference
but luke's planet had two suns not two
moons
and in fact multiple moons is quite
common even in our solar system did you
know mars has two moons
and fyi uranus has 27 moons orbiting it
i know that sounds like a joke but it's
actually a real fact uranus you get the
joke
over the next few hours the crew figure
out how to use the most advanced piece
of kit
they've ever seen in their lives and of
course we don't question it
they find a power supply and batman
deduces the zero point
is rapidly cycling through unlimited
realities every single second
the zero point is a doorway to any world
planet or universe by jerry rigging
deathstroke's energy staff to the power
supply
and simply shoving a dimensional panel
around the group
immediately power up the zero point and
coincidentally locate renegade raiders
home
let's not question how improbable that
is from the infinite worlds available
they find her homeworld hmm yeah don't
question it
and to do this they used vibrations yep
i kid you not each place in the
multiverse
has a different resonation key each
reality has a unique vibration which is
isolated
by those panels i honestly reckon if we
overthink this
it will lose all believability so let's
summarize in a general way
this machine as used by jonesy harnesses
the zero point and triangulates any
dimension
ever made yep that sounds like a good
explanation to me
renegade raider sees her home and just
like eternal voyager
she running yeets herself into the zero
point
and this time it's a success our girl
made it she made it
before the elation can begin batman has
a revelation to share with deathstroke
and now you don't need us anymore or
should i say your masters don't
the world's greatest detective after
pikachu of course figures it out
deathstroke killed fish sticks
to cover his tracks he killed the fish
and the electrical burns perfectly match
up with deathstroke's choice of weapon
there's no denying it batman actually
realized deathstroke didn't have amnesia
like the others
how else would he know that batman
carries liquid nitrogen
it's not a normal thing to carry around
and finally he hits the nail on the head
we know each other from our homeworld
don't we
as suspected deathstroke did indeed drop
kick bruce into the rift
all those weeks ago the truth is out
a huge battle begins as each member
decides which side
they stand on most align with batman but
bandalette chooses deathstroke
realizing they need each other to get
home a truce is called
bandalette isn't happy and comment
really get a girl all fired up and leave
her hanging
typical yep vandalite used cunning
linguistics and made a sex joke in a dc
comic book
by a fortnite character heroes don't do
that do they
moving on slade is tied up and vandalite
is returned home using the zero point
as other characters get back to their
home worlds the group realize
one person won't be going home at all
someone needs to man the panel
with only three people remaining batman
catwoman and himself deathstroke
he makes his move cutting himself free
and running towards the zero point
catwoman was totally ready for this and
stops his escape
and that's when we are hit with a huge
story update
deathstroke has a portal device it looks
teeny tiny in those big hands
that's better the portal device we last
saw used by agent jones to seal the
foundation in the zero point
the device was used to recruit history's
greatest heroes
including chunley's thighs and now it's
in deathstroke's possession
jumping into the zero point deathstroke
confirms the device is more like a
compass
using it to take himself back home we've
actually seen this in action before
this is what agent johnsy did to summon
the foundation
calibrating the device before throwing
it into the zero point
catwoman is able to disarm deathstroke
as he goes back to gotham and his last
line
sums up their predicament perfectly it's
not all bad
i mean you're stuck in a crazy alien
dimension forever but at least
you've got each other to be concluded
oh goosebumps
although the final shot doesn't show the
portal device we did see catwoman take
it from deathstroke
our heroes still have a way to get home
but can they figure out where home is
and how to use that portal gun find out
in two weeks in the final episode of
batman fortnite zero point
i gotta admit i'm loving the amount of
lore we are getting in this story so far
and something huge must happen next time
around
i'm adam you're awesome on screen now
are a bunch of code adamaru legends i'm
about six days behind in my twitter
replies so
sorry if you're still waiting but i will
get back to you if i haven't already
it's been a pleasure i'll see you next
[Music]
time
[Music]
you